This episode is supported by NordVPN.
Head over to nordVPN.com/microcosmos to learn
more about virtual private networks and internet security.
The microcosmos is not always a graceful space.
Sometimes an organism just needs to get around
the way it gets around, even if that means
looking like a swimming elephant head with
a truncated snout at one end and a rat tail
at the other.
Those odd creatures are called Bodonids, single-celled
eukaryotes with two flagella that create that
frantic movement.
They belong to a group of flagellated protists
called Kinetoplastida, and it was probably
a relief to James, our master of microscopes,
that the Kinetoplastids he found had two flagella.
If there was just one flagellum, he would
be dealing with the other half of the group:
the Trypanosomatids.
The family Trypanosomatida is made up entirely
of parasites that like to infect insects and plants.
But some, like Trypanosoma cruzi, the organism
responsible for Chagas disease, can make their
way over to humans via their insect hosts,
causing aches and fever and swelling among
a number of other symptoms.
There are some parasitic Bodonids, but those
ones tend to be found in fish and snails.
And the family relationship they have with
Trypanosomatids has made Bodonids a handy
organism to have around so that we can better
understand the diseases their relatives cause.
It’s a nice role for an organism that is
sometimes easy to miss against the backdrop
of the microcosmos.
Like if we hadn’t shown you what bodonids
look like already, and if we’d opened today’s
episode with this scene...
would you know what you are looking for?
I know I would probably have assumed they
were the green almond-shaped organisms, just
because their color and strange shape makes
them stand out so much more.
And even in this scene, where there are so
many more bodonids to see, they’re just
so secondary to the giant rotifer picking
away at their population.
Those other creatures are fascinating and
we’ve encountered them plenty of times on
our journey through the microcosmos.
But you know what they don’t have that Bodonids
and their fellow kinetoplastids do?
Chainmail.
Yes, chainmail.
But also fine, not actual chainmail.
Bodonids aren’t decorated in metallic loops.
What they have is actually something more
unique and fascinating—something that has
changed the way we see the molecules and processes
fundamental to life.
Kinetoplastids get their name from this unique
chainmail structure.
It’s called the kinetoplast, and it’s
found inside their mitochondrion.
The kinetoplast is unique, but its building
blocks aren’t:
it’s just DNA.
You know, that double helix found in all of
us, that molecule that holds the instructions
for how our cells look and behave.
When scientists were finally able to see the
kinetoplast under an electron microscope,
they realized that the DNA inside of it does
something kind of funny.
It forms thousands and thousands of tiny little
circles, along with around 25 to 50 larger circles.
And those circles of DNA link together, building
a structure that, in many kinetoplastids,
looks a lot like chainmail.
Scientists have done all sorts of experiments
to learn more about this DNA.
But one of the most important things they’ve
learned isn’t about DNA—it’s about DNA’s
single-stranded cousin RNA.
We said earlier that DNA is like the instruction
manual that tells our cells what to do.
But an instruction manual is just a stack
of paper if no one is around to read it.
So inside of cells, there is a mechanism in
place to read that DNA, transcribing it into
a single-stranded genetic material called
messenger RNA.
You can think of that RNA as like someone
reading aloud from the instruction manual.
After, that messenger RNA’s words get translated
into action, producing a protein that can
go on to serve some function in the cell.
That process—DNA transcribed to RNA and
then translated into protein—forms what
many of us know as the central dogma of biology.
It is beautiful, it is elegant.
And it is also far too simplistic for what
life actually looks like.
There are many ways that process is more complicated
than what we originally said, but we’re
here for the kinetoplastids and their strange
DNA chain mail.
One of the unusual things researchers in the
1980s noticed as they studied kinetoplast
DNA is that there were genes that almost coded
for things we knew they should code for.
The sequences in them created instructions
that looked like they should make a particular
protein found in these organisms, but something
would be off.
Mutations would shift the instructions slightly,
almost as if it were missing key words or
someone had deleted a step in the instruction
manual.
But that was in the DNA.
When they studied the RNA, the instructions
were suddenly correct again, almost as if
they had been edited to make sense.
In fact, that’s what the researchers would
call the process: RNA editing.
This process turned up over and over again
in the kinetoplastids.
Nonsensical instructions in the DNA would
make sense later thanks to RNA editing, a
biological process poking at the person reading
from the manual to correct their final message.
Kinetoplasts aren’t the only organisms to
use RNA editing, and it’s not quite clear
what advantages there are to the process.
Perhaps it allows a single gene to encode
multiple proteins.
Perhaps it’s a necessary adaptation to contend
with mutations.
Or perhaps it’s some other explanation we
don’t even know enough to imagine now.
Bodonids are not the only microbes that force
us to reevaluate the fundamentals.
Microbes are constantly showing us different
ways to do the basics,
and inspiring new techniques in the process.
Tools like CRISPR are rooted in this kind
of reevaluation, this expansion and complication
of our dogmas.
This is usually the point in an episode where
I want to end by sighing and saying,
“All that, and this organism is just living its
life!
It doesn’t know!”
Because that is sometimes what it feels like.
Hundreds of words about this invisible process
buried deep in this funny, flagellated creature
that doesn’t know what we’re even talking
about.
It doesn’t know why we’ve spent all this
time looking at it and studying it.
And even if it did, would it really care?
It has a whole life to live, a life that will
continue long after I’m done talking about
RNA editing.
And we will never get to know what the entirety
of that life is.
Only that it involves chainmail made of DNA,
circles of information linked together to
produce questions we will chase forever.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you to NordVPN for supporting this
episode.
NordVPN takes internet safety seriously and
you should too.
NordVPN provides you a secure, encrypted tunnel
for your online traffic to flow through.
Nobody can see through the tunnel, get their
hands on your online data, or find your real
IP address and location.
Now when you’re working out of your local
coffee shop and are worried about joining
that sketchy looking FREECUSTOMERWIFI network,
you can have the peace of mind and securely
access personal information or work files,
encrypt your internet connection, and keep
your browsing history and online identity
private.
Enjoy online privacy and security with NordVPN.
They have super fast servers in over 60 countries
and they have 24/7 customer support with live
chat or emails
And right now, for a limited time, you can
get an exclusive 2 year plan with 1 month
free and a special gift if you go to nordvpn.com/MICROCOSMOS
and use code MICROCOSMOS!
It’s risk-free with Nord’s 30 day money
back guarantee, and that link again is nordvpn.com/microcosmos.
The link is in the description.
The names on the screen right now are our
Patreon patrons, some of the people who have
decided to directly support this channel over
at patreon.com/journeytomicro.
Without them our channel could not exist,
so we want to say thank you to all of them.
If you want to see more from our master of
microscopes, James Weiss, you can check out
Jam & Germs on Instagram and TikTok.
And you can also find Journey to the Microcosmos
on TikTok now if you want some Micro Microcosmos
a couple times a week, and if you want to
see more from us here on YouTube, there is
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.